I think the biggest thing is the
internet in my opinion is probably as
profound or if not a more profound
invention and the the printed book and
or the computer itself almost because
it's linked the world together in one
cloud and that's incredible so that it's
possible for a small business person now
to reach markets that that just 10 years
ago were unthinkable so you can sell
products all over the world if you have
that type of distribution also you can
bring together markets very very quickly
you can create markets by having a
common social interest or a common need
for a product that heretofore was
unheard of I'll give you an example of i
happen to be a boater and love boats
well ten years ago if you want to buy
both so you kind of drove around a boat
yards and looked at ads in the local
neighborhood today you can go online and
see 100,000 boats for sale all over the
country with people more than willing to
ship them to you so I think it's changed
the way we do business I think it's very
you